Julian one of the things that comes
across in your life in the way in which
you engage with people and with
movements is this abounding positive
energy that and and this humorous way
about you and also very complex way
because not only have you been an
activist but you narrated a
oscar-winning documentary you hosted
Saturday Night Live and you did and you
were recently was in the it where I was
in the oscar-winning movie ray what is
it about you that we can learn about how
to keep up that that spirit that
enthusiasm when when there is so much
crisis around us I don't know why I have
a good-natured personality I'm sure it
comes from my family and my mother and
my father and the circumstances in which
they raised me and raised my siblings I
can't attributed anything else but that
that's the only thing I could say Jesus
it comes on i dunno i grew up on a
college campus and pennsylvania Lincoln
University in Pennsylvania and one of
the young women who grew up on that
campus with me is written a book about
growing up on this college campus and
remember there are black kids white kids
kids of all kinds growing up children of
faculty members going to school together
intermixing with each other all the time
and in writing this book she has
interviewed most of the people who are
my peers people who Maya my age as we
were growing up on this campus and to a
man and a woman they described just
awful times the school bus driver
molesting that showed the girls other
people treating them badly just terrible
things me I describe just a lovely time
wonderful time nothing bad ever happened
just a great day happy go lucky so and I
don't know no one molested me which is a
horrible thing you know and I didn't
know that this was going on or I would
think I would have had a different take
on it but I don't know why I look at
things through sunshiny glasses and
other people look at them in other ways
so I don't know i'm not saying i was
blind to sexual abuse because surely had
i known of
and I would have been you know horrified
by it but it happened over here and I'm
over here and for some reason or another
it didn't intrude into my world and as a
consequence I attribute my years on this
campus is just wonderful years and
almost to a man a woman each of them has
some horror story to tell not about
sexual abuse but horror story to tell
about their growing up years and it
didn't happen to me